uh dude let's talk about free britney
what do you think
um oh yeah i was gonna say a second ago
okay
you don't you're not the gossip about
all the [ __ ] talk we do guys all right
not everything used to be a free britney
podcast okay
i um when did you watch it i watched it
like four days ago or something
yeah same something like that
sunday i think i watched it what if i
just came in here like you know i agree
with her dad
that [ __ ] is crazy that [ __ ] is crazy
and
i think he did the right thing i think
actually she deserved it
i think
it's crazy offensive
honestly i agree with the brother yeah
dude how much of a dick was that guy man
oh
god bro brother that guy is stuck i
can't believe they just kind of let that
slide by like they were like and then
his brother got interviewed briefly
by this like radio host and the brother
is like what did he say he said
yeah i don't know the women in the
family are just kind of strong-willed
and they just like they like to do what
they want sucks being one of the two
guys in the family though yeah
yeah else was like sounds kind of
constitutional man it sounds like
yeah but these women are just
free-willed like it sounds like that's
kind of fine and he was like yeah i know
crazy the host hit him with some
questions and he
he and then he had like a well yeah like
one of those moments
yeah or he ate a [ __ ] gummy worm well
well
um no then he ended he said so have you
talked about
have you talked to brittany about this
and he's like yeah of course i mean
she's wanted to get out of it for like
years now but
you know we'll see where it ends up it's
like
yeah is that an answer to this question
she's being held
hostage she's a prisoner and you're like
yeah we'll see where it ends up what
does that even mean
we'll see where it ends up the whole i
think that whole stint
of crazy [ __ ] that people said about her
i didn't you know i didn't even realize
the extent that people
went to with like bagging on her
i just remember like she shaved her head
and people called her psycho and i
and i thought i don't i don't think
that's
that crazy i mean they
i don't know it is a pretty wild thing
to do nowadays maybe not
because it's like but back then
that was a pretty weird thing to do i
mean it was abnormal it was definitely
abnormal
and like but like the way the media
painted it was like especially with
those pictures
that was interesting is hearing the
background of that famous picture of her
like
you know looking crazy at the paparazzi
yeah
like beat his car or whatever um very
rarely do i get a urge to like
want to hurt somebody i want to knock
that paparazzi out oh my god that guy
he's like yeah we needed each other
you know it was like totally mutual no
like mutual respect there like she
needed me i needed no
[ __ ] off dude no your career
was in unnecessary nobody needed you
yeah i mean like i don't know
i don't know like it yeah it it had to
have been hell to be like an a-list
celebrity at like the peak of tabloid
culture
you think about social media kill the
tabloids yeah it did and
good yeah you know yeah i i i
you know i was actually thinking all it
would take to murder tmz
is for like ad services you know like
third party like even like google
adsense and [ __ ] like if they
just like ban like the domains like oh
tmz nah we don't serve ads
to that that would goodbye yeah i think
they'd be gone
yeah overnight because their traffic
doesn't come from television i feel like
so much of it is the internet
with tmz you know yeah modern day
tabloids yeah
yeah yeah but the problem is they can
just sell ads themselves
yeah that's the problem and people still
buy them remember like twice
remember uh ign used to like
you ever go on ign.com uh not english
not a ton not really no
was it ign yeah it wasn't indian i used
to go on
gaming news and they used to brand their
entire website
with whatever ad company bought it oh
yeah they do like yeah they do those
full-on takeovers yeah
like the whole website was themed like
the entire background was the cover of
the video game that was being advertised
i usually thought that was
insane but they were probably making
money for that oh huge
bro this is like [ __ ]
ugh like weird flashbacks but i remember
i had i was working on some kind of page
takeover like that and
i just remember being pure hell trying
to write that kind of experience
into a targeted ad
like placement oh my [ __ ] god i can't
even imagine
every time they went to do one of those
full-page takeovers like it must have
been like a development
[ __ ] nightmare you just got people
you know making tons of money off it
they're like just
i we told them that we could cover the
whole page and the developers like whoa
why
why the [ __ ] would you say that you're
like dude i was just you know
someone said it was possible we got to
figure this out yeah
though the the uh the the asset that
they gave us though
it can't be perfectly centered it has to
be five pixels to the right because the
title
uh you know is shifted a little bit to
the right so what do you mean it has to
be fi
what yeah yeah you just have to move
everything just gotta move it five
pixels
everything yeah that's gonna [ __ ] up the
whole [ __ ] layout of the site
yeah but these two anime titties are in
the cover and they want the titties
showing so they'd five
seconds five thousand you just wouldn't
if you wouldn't mind it's just one of
mine
in the next hour too if you don't mind
thank you bro
ad development oh my god i've never
bruh bruh bro
those are the some of the dumbest most
frustrating people i've encountered in
my entire life
we used to we used to like code
experiences
like for stuff that was on tv and film
and you'd have you'd have print people
walking up to our monitor with [ __ ]
rulers and like
edges of paper trying
like putting that on the screen like to
line [ __ ] up
and then they would like go to their
computer and then come to mind and be
like
it just it seemed like it wasn't and
then they put a ruler up and it'd be
dead ass center
or like you know on one line they go ah
that's weird
yeah it's on my computer it didn't look
right it's like the [ __ ] same on
everyone
you think i have a hard-coded that it
changes for whatever [ __ ] model
that's funny some of the dumbest people
oh yeah i made it [ __ ] up on yours
yeah purposely
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] bruh like they like they
didn't understand that
um monitor displays like have like kind
of differing colors or you know like
some monitors are shitty so monitors are
good
so we get a ton of that or like the red
just doesn't seem the same red and i'm
like
yeah just die you're not meant for this
era just go away
anyway sorry sorry ptsd but now it's
fine
yeah no i i um i agree with her brother
i think
[Laughter]
it would suck honestly having like
strong minded females strong-winded
women in your house
and you're outnumbered you're one of the
two guys in the family pretty
emasculating to be honest
like [ __ ] would suck we should talk more
about the bride
yeah i think that i think that the if if
the people who didn't get enough
attention in the documentary the brother
kevin fetterline the devil jt too you
know i think justin dillon
deserved a little bit more shine in that
documentary they painted him
in a really negative dude he was
oh man when you see it i don't know
you know i feel like i
i you know when people talk about like
the patriarchy now and stuff like that
yeah like but in the not like the [ __ ]
that jay leno said about
brooklyn yeah boobs on like live tv
the way justin timberlake just treated
her and was like totally
everyone was cool with that that's
[ __ ] up dude
i never knew jay leno said that [ __ ] i'm
[ __ ] my [ __ ]
my jaw hit the floor i'm like this is
crazy like i was thinking about that
line he just said and how many people
are like oh my god
how many old people are like jay leno
was such a showman
such a showman like
oh it's like tattoos just getting on the
internet being like hey get a load of
these girls weird boobs
like you look at that and you'll be like
we've come a long way in terms of toxic
max
masculinity i think we're doing pretty
good
considering that that used to be totally
acceptable that was
totally fine yeah britney spears is you
know waxing her boobies or whatever what
did these even say
yeah okay can we get the quote hold on
it was something i like he said it and i
was like what that's not
like some weird sketch or something she
just got
i mean i don't know maybe it's just the
way that the documentary painted the
whole thing but she got stomped on man
it's like
she just no matter where she went it was
like a
thousand camera dudes like don't drive
anyone [ __ ] crazy
i mean yes and the way she and then the
way she was just
constantly talked about in the media
like
which is all about sex is it never not
about her like sexual
life yeah it's like who the [ __ ] do you
imagine publicly talking about whether
or not
someone in the in the spotlight is a
virgin
nowadays what the [ __ ] is that
that okay so that i have two things one
that part to me was
was like genuinely [ __ ] sick that's
[ __ ] gross yeah 18 19 year old girl
and you're a grown ass man being like
so what's up with that hyman
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah welcome to the
show
you're on national tv what's up with
have you [ __ ] it
has anybody [ __ ] in
yeah you messing around at all
getting your [ __ ] puss rammed huh
whole audience like
hey come on tell the people what's up
with you we want to know
who have you sucked off recently anyone
had how did that reporter ask that
question and no one in that room
beat that guy's [ __ ] head no that's
true
i had nobody next to him well like yo
you're a [ __ ] creep
just like knocking his ass out cause
that's what i'm saying it was like that
was
normal yeah hey so
uh are you still evading
yeah i'm gay but the audience wants to
know
i don't care i don't care i don't care i
wouldn't suck on those boobies
bro the other thing that pissed me off
was like
i don't want to hear any okay that
conservative ass mom reporter
who was like being ultra critical of her
like to the point where she cried
what was her she had like the little you
know yeah she had like that little boy
scout haircut
one thing that struck me was like
i feel like a lot of old uh like
entertainment
interviewers were like kind of like that
or like people like
i just have memories of like barbara
[ __ ] um
walters type people interviewing pop
stars and [ __ ]
and then there's like i feel like
there's this clear like shaming
that they're doing like in the
documentary and just you know from that
period i feel like
that kind of furthers that like you're
not a good girl
why are you showing cleavage it's like
[ __ ] you just cause you're old and you
look like [ __ ] and you're upset that
someone is like looks better than you
you old [ __ ]
[ __ ] you first of all yeah and secondly
i i don't think anyone can be critical
of brittany
especially like old people because like
to your point about like a thousand
cameras in your face everywhere you go
[ __ ] cameron [ __ ] can't handle a
cell phone camera
yeah you know when they're like getting
irate so exactly
yeah yeah you got 60 cameras and you
watch
that thing get you stop filming that's
illegal you need my consent
to film yeah
i mean and it was like and for the vast
majority of the clips they showed she
was like
exceedingly calm in the yeah the
paparazzi like she
never blew up ever like even when they
were in front of her car she was trying
to get out of
she never had security with her either
like she was just her
there's like these sweaty fat dudes like
like you know over her with the camera
and she never once was like
freaked out or or like looked like she
felt overly threatened it's like you
gotta have a
pretty level head to like be cool in
that situation and um
what the [ __ ] oh yeah it's like the
epitome of like building someone up to
tear them down like the way that the
media just talks about her like
in a sexual sense over and over and over
again and then as soon as she's like
started showing cleavage they're like
you're a [ __ ] yeah
it's like but you mate you created this
what are you talking about like
yeah you forced her to like i don't it's
just bizarre it's like you made this
part of her image and now she's like
trying to just be a woman and you're
like
i think that was like kind of one of the
interesting parts about all this is that
i think now when people get popular
weirdly
you see like audiences feel responsible
for
caring about the person which i think is
a it's a newer thing
you know or like what do you mean or or
maybe it's newer
what i mean is a tabloid could just like
wreck your like image and who you are
like
indiscriminately and there's no voice
for your fans who maybe
disagree with that or you know
want to push back against that what i'm
saying is now
i feel like there's this notion that if
you're a fan of someone and if that
artist or that person says
i'm feeling down or this feels like too
much or whatever
like i feel like now audiences feel
responsible for being like yo
like you know we should support this
person and
if they see shitty comments like they're
the first ones to be like [ __ ] you
they're going through something you
don't know what it's like to be them
like blah blah
whereas i feel like in the tabloid era
you couldn't really do that
like a tablet could just be like this
person's a [ __ ] and then
everyone just has to okay that's it like
there's no refuting that there's no
going against it yeah because i just
feel like tabloids and all that could
just like
take one thing and pile it on and then
just run with that
yeah and like what were you if you were
some person who's like i don't think
brittany's a [ __ ] what the [ __ ] can you
do about it
yeah so you're right into the tabloids
yeah stop it
don't print that leave britney alone
yeah
and everyone makes i mean yeah the media
could just
there was one narrative and
that was the problem is that it was so
like especially with the jt [ __ ] it was
so
um you know like i don't know it was
like male i don't
just [ __ ] they they preferred
justin's
side of the story you know what i'm
saying yeah and they could just easily
beat her down and so that's exactly what
the narrative was
well i think it just like it feels a lot
of that [ __ ] like horseshit like
old-school conservative ideology where
it's just like
oh you know this is what a lady looks
like this is what a
you know a young woman is supposed to
behave like then
brittany it's always like highlighting
like look how [ __ ] she is you know
what i mean
like yeah i don't know stupid